all right
Larry Larry uh where'd you grow up where
you from originally Queens New York
Queens and tell me about your family
growing up you had Mom and Dad Mom and
Dad yeah they were just working people
my mother and um she was a seamstress
but she uh she wind up running um dress
factories for uh a pretty big outfit and
my father just was a truck
driver what kind of kid were you as a
teenager
how how how was I yeah I was a defiant
kid I was uh I I wanted to do what I
wanted to do when I wanted to do it and
U and probably I'm the only um thing my
mother ever failed at trying to
normalize me I I I knew early on I I
just was different even I I I was very I
I had an obsession I I I I just I had a
win no matter what it was marbles or
Scully or whatever it was I I had a win
and
um um and I did whatever I had to do to
do it I I I didn't want to be a part of
a baseball team I just because there was
other players on a team that might screw
up and cause you to lose the game I I
wanted to do something where I was in
complete charge and that's probably what
saved me from um getting involved in
gangs even though I did for a very short
period of time and uh be influenced by
all the mob guys because every every the
neighborhood I grew up in Italian
neighborhood um and every Italian
neighborhood was basically like Chaz
petar's movie of the Bronx Tale same
same thing and uh you know you're young
kid 13 145 you you get you know you see
pretty girls and big diamond rings and
gold chains and nice cars and and that's
what you want um and I stayed on that
corner about a day or two until I found
out that um you kind of had to follow
the leader and I didn't want to follow
any leader I wanted to do what I wanted
to do and that's and and that's what I
did so in some ways um it it saved me um
from getting
involved um even even when I crossed the
line I I I crossed it by myself uh when
I got caught I got caught by
myself uh and when I succeeded I
succeeded by myself until uh my
obsession with
speed and
um and and and competition and and
everything that I was obsessed
about until it turned into an
addiction and um the addiction was a
tough one I never thought
is is I'm pretty strong guy I learned
through the years based on other people
around me I I realize that I'm I'm a lot
stronger will than than most and um and
um I I um I could adjust to any
situation almost instantly whether it's
having 10 million in my pocket or 0 and
10 million I just
adjust and the thing that's saved me
because there were a lot of bad spots I
got myself into uh was music I could I
and back then in the 60s and 70s there
was a um a nightclub on just about every
corner in every neighborhood with music
in it and and I love I I just love music
if somebody said look when you walk out
this door at midnight you're going to
get you're going to get a shot in the
head um I'd walk into the place at 9:00
and from 9 till midnight and listen to
music and that thought wouldn't even
enter my mind I just get zoned out and
uh that that's that's what saved me
there were a lot of tough times uh I
went through and I just hop in into a
nightclub and um the problem with that
got to
be um later
on um when I was doing what I I
did um was that every nightclub where
the music was where I wanted to go and
have AG go um was owned by a mob
guy and um and before you know it they
find out what you do and what you do for
a living and everybody wants a piece
everybody wants a piece of the
action and normally I would tell them
u i don't come into your
place at the end of the weekend and take
half the money that's in the drawer why
are you asking me for information
information on Races that I may have
fixed but um you can't say that
especially back in the 50s and 60s and
70s when the mob was uh the
mob and
um you just get caught up in that um if
if you want I can tell you how it all
started or I yeah that'd be great horse
racing was your was your addiction well
yeah uh from the time I was from the
time I was I think six or seven years
old I graduated from skates and
skateboards and and and little box
cars um to um I sent away for um a a kit
that you could build a go-kart in fact
that's how I I ruined my eyes because
when the kit came I had to sell like
$500 worth of grass seat or something to
get a kit mail to me that included um a
pipe bender electrical contu bik right
in in a in a an electric welder with
rods and a mask and directions how to
put it all
together and um when how I hurt my eyes
was that the rod when the rods got there
they were a little damp and every time
I'd go to strike it I would lose the
spark and I'd have to pull the mask up
and that went on for a half hour until
finally when when I got the spark I I
never M pulled the mask on I just
squinted my eyes well completed the the
frame of the cart and about two or three
hours later it felt like somebody poured
sand in my eyes and and I screwed up my
eyes pretty bad and ever since then I
wore black glasses I'm trying now with
these glasses that go light when you're
in the yeah yeah that yeah and U it's
not working too good because I'm always
squinting but anyway
uh I started out racing cars uh by the
time I was 14 I was I had a I built a
stock car I was racing out of Freeport
and um and I built a dragster I had a 32
Ford rooster in in 1956 I I was 16 years
old I put a um a 55 Chevy engine in it
and I won B Roadster every week at West
Hampton on Sunday and I built the
draxer the the the and and and I was
happy that that's what I wanted to do I
loved I I I loved I don't know which I
like better speed and competition or or
music um girls came third um and uh um
and and in fact if a girl tried to
bother me when when the band was playing
I would just do me a favor go go get out
of here and that's how zoned out I got
with
music so um through the years the next
maybe year and a half two years I had a
room full of trophies from the stock car
and drax's trophies and blankets and and
um to support that
Obsession
um I crossed the line pretty good I I
start robbing gas stations to get
whatever money I needed
to rebuild a clutch or or put an engine
in or what whatever I
needed and um and one day um I blew the
engine in a
dragster and
uh I needed about 4 500 and robbing gas
stations you get $30 $40 tops but I saw
a gas station on a stur Boulevard in
1002 Street in in East elmherst
Queens they was having a grand opening
the guy had a all brand new tires and
transmission jacks because in them years
or standard shift Transmissions there
all the cars were turning over to
automatic transmissions so you had to
have these big Jacks to take them down
they weighed a couple hundred pounds and
uh I says that's the place I'm going to
rob and I did I robbed the box truck and
um the night before and I I broke into
the building and I start loading all
this stuff up
and um I I sold it and U in about three
months later I got a knock on the door
was detective Sans from the 114 Precinct
in the story of
queens and uh they took me down to the
um Precinct and uh brought me upstairs
third
floor and uh they pushed a piece of
paper in front of me and they said
signed it and I said what is that he
said a confession and they said listen
before you start we have all the stuff
you robbed we have the guy who so you
sold it to just sign the confession save
yourself a lot of trouble and me like a
16-year-old wise guy I says I ain't
signing nothing Well detective SS uh and
you got to remember back in them days it
was in the
50s U there was no such thing as you
have the right to remain silent and uh
the right to an attorney there was none
of that uh the first thing they did was
open the drawer and put a pair of pliers
on and thank God I used to bite my nails
because if you didn't they just attached
the pliers to One Nail and if you didn't
sign it they' pull it out or bring you
in the back and beat the out of
you so I says I'm not signing nothing
detective Sans gets up he walks around
the desk and um
he slaps me when he slapped me I hit him
in the belly hit him in the belly the
other two detectives in the rooms
handcuffed me to the back of the chair
Sans went and got a big book and start
pounding me on her head until I was I I
I was probably unconscious my my nose
was bleeding my eyes my ears everything
and and um they uncuffed me and they
asked me to sign it and I wouldn't sign
it and uh they hit me again I fell to
the floor crawled in the corner they
jumped on me
and uh the wind and and I crawled in a
fetal position I remember them getting
that pole that they used to push the
windows up with big long pole they start
jabbing me in the ribs and um and then I
woke up uh in the
tombs um one for and I guess all the
precincts they have cells down in the
basement and 114 had three cells down
there and they had um I think 1401 bulb
three cells 6 Ines of water on the
ground rats as big as cats and that's
where I stayed until Monday morning they
put me down there Thursday night I think
and Monday morning they come and get me
and they bring me to
uh a Queens Boulevard Courthouse I think
and
uh you got to remember this is 60 70
years ago I'm plus I'm old myself and I
forget a lot but uh they brought me
there and U my mother come and got me
and um when she come and got me I was my
clothes were full of blood my B dried
blood my ears and my eyes my nose my
mouth my head was split open my ankle
was as big as a basketball and I said Ma
you got to you got to get me to the
hospital I can't breathe and she says um
and and and my mother was a good woman
but she'd been through years and years
of trying to straighten me out and I was
just just defiant just and and I got
beaten every single day and it it made
no difference and and she never got a
phone call that was a good one from me
from school or from the time I was a kid
and she just about had enough and um she
she says I'm going to take you where I
should have taken you um years
ago and she took me to her boss the the
the dress factories that she ran were
for Tommy laesi Tommy laesi was three
finger brown one of the founding members
of kin ostra in the city um in fact it's
that that that crime family still
carries his
name and um he basically ran the city
between the other four guys U
mosses and um he said he said to he said
to my mother leave the room I want talk
to him alone and I I met him before he
he he came to my sister's wedding so I I
met him before but I I paid no attention
it made no difference what anybody did I
just wanted to do what I wanted to do
and it it made no difference to me if he
was the president or he was a stumble
bum it made no difference to me so um he
says to me he says
um he says you your mother's a good lady
and and she's my
friend and you're breaking a heart with
all your nickel and dime
and I want you to go home and I
want you to think about who I am and
what I
said and
um if you want to straighten your life
out I'll help you in any way that I can
and you'll never have a
problem including the one you have
now so just that talk from that guy
because then I I
realized who he was my mother told me
who he was at my sister's wedding when
we had to put a table all the way in the
corner for him and his five or six guys
and and he only stayed an hour and I
says where's he going and she explained
who he was and everything which made no
difference to me anyway but I knew he my
mother always taught me to respect your
elders and and and so he was my Elder
and I respected him and I called him Mr
Lai and so anyway um I went
home and uh on the way home um I started
well we went right to the hospital from
there and that's when I found out that I
had four or five broken ribs I was in
the hospital a few
days and uh and while I was in there um
and home I I thought about what he said
which I never thought about in my whole
life I never thought about breaking my
mother's heart I just I was I
was I was very selfish like I just I
didn't think about anybody I never heard
anybody on purpose
but I did whatever I had to do to get
the job done and that was that was
getting money and raise my
cars but I start thinking about this
woman who who who raised me and uh
taught me all the right things and I
knew all the right things and that's why
I knew what I was doing was not right
and and and and I knew that I was
different from the other kids I was
completely
different and
uh
um I said I'm I'm I'm going to I'm going
to go straight I'm I'm going to go
straight and I told my mother I says M
I'm I'm all done I I'll get a job
legitimate job and everything so I I did
but I wanted to get a job where I I
still had my OBS OBS Obsession I had a
race I I that's what I wanted to do more
than anything in in the whole
world um and uh so I went and look for
jobs in a gas station and I knew the
perfect gas station it was open all
night so I went there and it was on
Northern Boulevard in East Elmhurst it
was an old black area and it was a
pretty bad area it between Jackson
Heights then East Elmhurst and then
Corona which was all Italian so it was
Italian black and then
Italian and um I went into the gas
station and they're always looking for
night help they were on Northern
Boulevard with which is the probably the
busiest Boulevard and queens and uh or
goes right into Manhattan and um they
they um they needed they were open 24
hours and they they always needed a
night watch or a night uh attendant so I
I went in there and I asked the guy
because he always had a sign at a window
because he used to work the nights until
he got somebody and I said listen I'll
work the night shift if you let me park
my cars there and and uh and work on
them uh during my working hours and he
said no problem but there's something
you should know you you know you're a
young guy and uh this area is not the
greatest and we we get robbed every once
in a while and I says that's not a
problem for me as long as you allow me
to keep my cars here and work on them
that was more important to me besides
the fact that I was the one that was
robbing the gas stations at night so
that part didn't bother me
and that's what I did and uh I worked
and for the first couple of months I
worked on my cars I fixing them all up
on sa Saturday uh Fridays I I'd go to
West Hampton and I mean a Freeport stock
cars and in Sundays Westampton and
everything was going well um and
whatever money I was earning I was able
to repair
whatever broke down with the cars and
then one day A horsse van pulled in and
he asked me to fill the truck up and uh
he asked me for a bucket of water when I
got got the bucket of water he's up in
the truck with three
horses and I says what are you doing
with them horses he says I'm going to
yak's RaceWay I says you race them
things and he says yeah so we through
the conversation I found out that you
race horses for
money and um with the stock cars and
drags and Ro you get
trophies and um he invited me out to the
farm um I'll skip right through this
because it it'll go on forever he
invited me out to the farm within a year
he taught me everything that that that
he knew and and uh and we um he he
helped me get my trainer's license and
driver's license to drive the Trotters
not the thoroughbreads the trots there
horness racing that's what I was in and
Thor bread racing even though later on I
was in both of them but but this
particular uh my first my first um
license was for um driver and train of
honors
racing so um I called up my mother and
and I said ma says I got my
license uh to train and drive horses and
uh um and I I wanted to tell her that
because she was I told her what I was
doing and she was anxious for me and
finally she was getting phone calls from
me that didn't involve me in a hospital
or in a Precinct
someplace um or in the Dean's office in
school so
um um she called me the next day and she
says come home I I have something for
you so I went home um the horse farm was
amer's horse farm out in Long Island my
mother lived in Jackson Heights so I
went home and she gave me an envelope
and the envelope was $20,000 she says
this is from Mr Lai he's very happy for
you and he said buy whatever you need to
buy whatever horses equipment and if you
need more just let them know and that's
what I did I went to uh I went bought
some horses I stabled them at the farm
and my mentor at that time was the guy
who taught me everything was Mike Foley
trainer driver and
uh I applied for stalls at Rosevelt now
back
then in the 60s Y yakas and roselt were
the two major racetracks for horness
racing in the whole country and all the
top drivers and horses were there and um
the license I was given was a
provisional license when you just
beginning you're just in like an a
provisional
driver I didn't know but uh they didn't
allow provisional drivers to drive at
them big racetracks the major
tracks and that was also the reason they
they didn't give me stalls so I call up
my mother I says Ma I says I I don't
know what to do I took Mr Lai gave me
$20,000 I bought four horses everybody's
happy but now they wouldn't give me
stalls to race them and he says I have
to go to all these small tracks out of
town and uh you know I don't I I don't I
don't know what to do I don't have any
money to go out of town I never been on
my own with the horses I don't know so
she says um let me talk to Tommy see
what he says I says I just don't want
him to think that I'm I'm lying or
anything she calls me the next day and
she says take your four horses Shi in
the Roosevelt Raceway these four stalles
waiting for you I says how did how did
he do that and she says well Rosevelt
Raceway is owned by um
um Roosevelt Raceway is owned by uh
Morton Levy and Morton Levy was the
attorney for Frank Costello and Luc
Lucky Luciano and all them guys so he he
was a mob attorney owned the racetrack
so all it took was one phone call and
that's that's how I got in and they also
let me
drive and then
um and
then um there was a big stink because
all these professional guys that were
doing it their whole life who's this kid
and but I won seven out of the first
races there against the top guys in the
country
and um I got a big write up in a
newspaper full page write
up and um the the the reporter also um
interviewed some of the top
drivers uh I mean Stanley Dany George
schy and Billy hton who were the top
guys in the business at the time and
they all gave me good reviews they just
said the kid has unbelievable Talent all
all good stuff except Shelty said um I
don't know who this kid is all I know is
you can't give him an inch in the close
horse race and that's cuz I beat him two
nights in a row by an inch right at the
wire and I I loved it I I I loved horse
racing more than I love racing
cars and and um you know you you can't
fall in love with a bumper or a fender
but you can fall in love with a horse
and and that and that's what I did so
now I had I I I just love taking care of
the the horses and I learned through
hanging with the veterinarians for years
um how to recognize lameness how to
treat lameness and H how to keep a
horse's body sound and and both body and
and mind and um I was good at it because
I loved it and during the day I'd have
Sinatra playing on the radio and I'd be
doing the horses and I it it was just I
just loved
it when I got to when I got Roosevelt
meet was over um I was getting phone
calls from everybody because the the
[Music]
um the uh the newspapers um put me on a
pedestal that I was the greatest and all
of that stuff and I did good and I
probably deserved what they wrote but uh
I wasn't used to that kind of publicity
and all of a sudden the phone start
ringing I start getting messages
everybody want to give me their horses
and and money to buy horses they wanted
me to be their trainer and
driver and uh that's what happened the
meet ended and I went to yaka Raceway
which is same level as Roosevelt same
people same horses same guys the only
difference is that yakas was owned
by a
sleazy guy called Marty Tannon bom who
was I found this out later I didn't know
at the time he was just very very
politically involved with the Democratic
party and and accused many times of
embezzlement and everything just just a
sleev bag but he owned a racetrack and
he got licensed because of his political
connections so anyway I raced a horse
one night and U strictly legit I was
100% legit to to to a
fault and I raced the horse legit and um
I had to make a decision real early in
the race either to pull out or stay in
and we still had three quarters of a
mile ago so I just says I'll stay in
hopefully I'll get loose down the
stretch well I didn't and I finished the
race I finished third climbing over the
winter and what I found out later was
that Marty Tanner bomb uh he was
partners with another big the biggest
Gambler in in in in harness racing at
the time his name was Morty
finder um and I found what I'm about to
say now I found out 15 20 years
later that Morty Morty uh Morty finder
was partners with tanon bomb on beding
horses Morty finder was legitimate
Gambler in fact they had tanon bomb had
his own window uh where he could nobody
else could bet at that window except him
he had his own private teller and they
were Partners they put up 20,000 30,000
,000 each every night and back then that
they they were getting 20 30,000 people
a night at the racetrack and they were
handling 5 six million a night so a a a
big bet a 10 $220,000 BET was was uh was
not out of the ordinary for for them
them kind of
guys but um I got beat they bet on me
and um and Nat just like every other
Gambler he had to make an excuse while
he got beaten so he he called up tanon
bomb because they had a direct line to
one another tanon bomb stayed in his
office and and Morty finder stayed at
the table in a dining room so they had
the phone and um he says uh we should
have won they bet 10,000 on me he says
we should have won that bed that kid
stiffed that horse we should have won he
went off a three to one we should have
so anyway I didn't know this I get back
to the paddock and The Paddock judge
says uh he calls me he says the judges
want to see in the morning next morning
I go see the judges they said um Mr Tan
bomb uh gave you 24 hours to vacate the
grounds get your horses out of here and
I said For What and they says because he
said it he owns the racetrack he has the
right to do it so I call up my mother
and I says Ma and I told her the problem
she says well I can't bother Tommy
because he's in a hospital with a
malignant brain
tumor and um I had no choice but to pack
up I had some money that I won and start
going to all these small Mickey Mouse
racetracks around the country the
problem with that was half the horses I
had were better than the horses at these
small racetracks so they didn't ride any
races for them so I all I did was
basically stable them there and kept
them in in
training um and um the purse money was
nothing like a $10,000 purse at Yonkers
or Rosevelt
they would race for the tracks I was at
now $800 and and it was a joke if you
win you get 50% of that and it's just a
joke there was no money and it was only
a matter of maybe six seven months I was
out of
money and uh I had to
start figuring out a way how to feed
these horses and how to eat myself and
and between the other Grooms there that
um that were at the track and you have
to understand that all all these small
racetracks
Nationwide um they race for no money
most of them race because they were
either born into it or just for the love
of the horse and race and they all have
and everybody's broke half half the
people they are living in tack rooms and
raising their kids on the dirt in the
shed row and it's just it's it's
pitiful so um what happened was
um one day after about four year three
years four years
um of eating pigeons and brand mashes
and oats and grass and what whatever I
could
get um Lincoln Downs opened they made a
big advertisement Lincoln Dows is a
racetrack in
Boston and um they always had
thoroughbread racing
there and this was the first year they
were going to try harness racing
so I applied for stalls there and I was
a little anxious because the purses
would double there so I'll would be
racing for decent money and maybe I get
races for all my horses so I couldn't
wait to get there sure enough they gave
me the Stalls I shipped up there the
first day I have two horses in and both
Morning Line favorites so I'm sitting in
the barn in the morning and down the
shedro comes these three big guys they
look like the front line of the Green
Bay Packers big
guys and they reach me and they say um
you Larry roler I says yeah he says my
name is Tony Schuler I'm with h Winter
Hill Gang Whitey Bulger we run
everything in this
town including the racetracks so if
you're interested in making any money uh
we should talk so I says what' you have
in mind now at that time you have to
understand that I went for three four
years of eating pigeons and oats and
grass and I just wanted to jump up and
kiss this guy as big and ugly as he was
right on a lips just for saying you want
to make some money and the shot of
making money on the other hand I grew up
around these kind of guys these
big big jerks that you know mob guys
that they just try to intimidate you and
and and there wasn't nobody that can
intimidate me uh I knew that life I grew
up with it even though I was never never
a part of it mainly because I could
never Follow the Leader I could never
follow
anybody so he says uh I saids what you
have in mind he says you got two Morning
Line favorites I'll give you 200 a horse
and I just tell me the Stalls they're in
I'll have my vet go down and um you know
he'll do whatever he does and the horses
they'll finish up the track and uh
you'll make
400 so I said um I he said listen
um I want 500 a
horse and tell your vet to stay
home and he looks at me like he says are
you nuts do you know who you're
talking
to he says well really don't make a
difference who I'm talking to he says if
you want to deal with deal that's the
deal so he counts out a th000 bucks he
hands it to me he says you better be out
of the money you better be be worse than
third with both of these horses
cuz I'll be back in the morning I says
good I says bring bring coffee with no
sugar and in a bagel with
cheese and he looks at me and he laughs
and he walks away well the next morning
he came back with the coffee and the
bagel and U he want a lot of money and
he said you did a good job and I says
well thank you he says uh you got one in
tonight he says and if you can get
anybody else that we can deal with I'll
give you piece of all the
action and that was easy to do because
everybody up there was broke so within a
week I had seven or eight other drivers
that we could bribe to be worse than
third and what they would doing they
were boxing they'd get three four guys
out in each race and the remaining three
four five horses they would box them in
exactas or trifectas or whatever gimmick
racing they had up there and that's how
they made the money and once you left
the favorite out first and second choice
all that money remains in the in the
wind poool so it makes a difference who
wins after that uh you get all the money
and that's that what that's what the
game was so one night a couple of weeks
go by we're making a lot of money now
I'm having steak every night and I'm
really everything is really getting good
and
um uh by by being a favorite but but
purposely losing yeah got it right so
once the favorites out of the money all
that 90% of the money in the wind poool
is on the favorite so once the
favorite's out all that money stays in
the wind pool and even if 100 to one
shot wins or even the third choice you
get all that money so uh or 90% of it
anyway and plus the 10 20 30% that the
racetrack takes out for gimmick races
whatever it's another story another
robbery um so uh one night one day he
comes to me he he used to come every
morning as he's walking away he says
listen he says uh you want any action he
says I got an edge on some hoops
tonight and at that time I didn't even
know what Hoops was but I found out
later on he was fixing college
basketball games so because I was doing
business with him and making money with
him I I wasn't going to start
questioning him I said whatever you do
for you do for me next morning he comes
there he gives me I I think it was three
or 4,000 and he says what's this he says
I been on the game forar he says and we
win I found out lately he was fixing
college basketball
games so every night uh I would you know
I I couldn't wait for him to come you
got anything yeah I got two games
tonight three and I was making more
money with the college basketball games
than I was fixing
races and I become
um I I I become obsessed with that too
so so now I have girls I have racing and
I have music and now I have um sports
betting and um after about two
months that Obsession became an
addiction a terrible
addiction and to jump forward a couple
of years
um I made millions of dollars fixing
races in the next two or three years
and
um um losing it bet in
sports because right after that the
football season came and and U nobody
ever wins Ben I think out of the 16
games uh statistically the player wins
three times you can't you can't win
Benton football but I I didn't know that
at the time plus I had an addiction and
I didn't care so I bet about 10 11 games
every weekend and and so the bottom line
was uh
I I I jump I'll jump Straight Ahead the
bottom line was I I lost over a million
dollar I was betting with two guys I was
up at monacello now at the
time and I was betting with the old
Jewish Maya Lansky guy uh who retired um
Bonnie
Cutler and he was about 80 years old at
the time and but he retired up in
monacello when he was taking action from
all the guys around in that town and um
and a mad man called
kabert Robert bachia from Jersey his
nickname was kert that's what everybody
called him kert now I didn't notice at
the time but
um he killed 17 guys he was got's button
guy in New Jersey he was just a mad just
just a a bad
guy and um I was dealing with him my
friend introduced me to him
um and
um I was betting with both of
them so through the course of the year I
lose close to a million dollars between
betonwood both of them now I ran out of
money and uh but I I the addiction was
overpowering it it I I know now that
because I could never understand because
I I was such a strong will person that
if you says oh I can't stop smoking I'd
say well then you're a a jerk you how
could you not stop I can't stop doing
drugs well you're a jerk well I couldn't
stop
gambling and I I think gambling
addiction is worse than the drugs in the
and and and drinking uh because all the
suicides take
place uh W with gamblers not drug
addicts even they die of overdoses and
not drinkers
um and um and when when when you if
you're a drug addict you could either
stop or or kill yourself when you're a
drinker you could either stop or or keep
getting drunk when you're a gambler you
go
broke and in my case owe a million
dollars to bad bad
people and uh what year was that that
was 72 yeah so I dollar back then it's a
lot of money a lot of money well it a
lot of money you know that's all re it's
all relative relative uh you know back
then the money when you when you're in
that kind of action it's becomes
Monopoly money you know it don't it
don't really don't don't mean nothing I
mean my father was making like $30 $40 a
week and and I was making four or 5,000
a night you know so it's it's it's all
relative in and whatever you're doing so
um so now I I made my last pay I was
always pay or collect on
Tuesdays so Tuesday come and I paid what
I owed 70 80,000 whatever it was to both
guys and I would go give cabert the
money and my some girl very good friend
Gina she lived in the same complex that
uh um
that Bonney lived in and and she used to
she used to make the payment for
me um make the bets and whatever it was
for me and uh she got very friendly with
him because she lived right next door to
him and uh she used to go and make him
coffee in the morning and have lunch
with him and they become very very
friendly so Bonney was never a problem
in fact bnie was the one that says every
time once in a while I go up there and
uh he would say why don't you stop this
you you're in a dead end no you could
never win and and and yeah when you're
addicted you don't want to hear that
you just yeah okay Bonnie
thank so now I have no money but I have
an
addiction so I get a hold of Gabbert and
I said listen I says I'm going to
Florida to buy some property which was a
lie knowing that he was going to say
exactly what he said I says I'm going to
Florida to buy some prop I won't be back
for two or 3 weeks so um I'll see you
when I get back and and knowing he was
going to say well that's not a problem
just call up I'll give you the line and
you bet over the phone then I said well
but if I lose I won't be here to pay you
and then he said what I knew he was
going to say well don't worry about it
when you come back we'll straighten
out they didn't know I was broke they
just figured I was the Cash Cow had a
lot of money in a business where I was
in big
action and they let me go I go to
Florida 3 weeks later I bet every week
three weeks later I'm stuck U almost
800,000 so now I can't make no more
excuses um and uh I have a decision
either run
away um kill myself or go back I went
back and uh cert guy picks me up at the
airport and he says U you want to go
home cuz he's waiting for you and he
says I got no
money he says well you got a problem he
calls up ker tells him bring me down
following morning so the following
morning I meet him and uh they bring me
he brings me down to cabert he's down at
Atlantic Highlands they had a
little julash joint there whatever and
um it's just like a typical typical mob
movie room in the corner is a little
round table three guys at the table with
cert smoking cigars drinking demitz
coffee and typical mob scene so we reach
him and um kber just gets up walks out
the back door we follow him down to the
The Boat
Basin they Park boats there and we
walked out on this deck and they get to
a boat and they get on a boat he bring
these downstairs they they drive out in
the ocean for a half hour or 40 minutes
whatever and um then the motor stopped
they bring me upstairs they put me in
this little
drum threw a couple of bags of cement
and pump some water in there and here
comes
kert he saids Sammy let you go too
far and that's on him you went too far
and that's on you now you tell me why I
shouldn't let this amend Harden and
throw you the
overboard and um I said cuz I could
pay and he said you could pay he looks
at Sammy and Sammy kind of stuck up for
me he says well you know boss he says um
we got a lot of money paid every week
he's in big action he could he could
pay and uh so conert says you could pay
okay he
says um you ow 380,000
the other half I owed to
Bonney he says I'm going to make this a
shlock loan two points a
week every week you come and see Sammy
with 7200 you miss one week and you'll
be right back here with no turning
back all right holds me off he brings me
back home and I tell Gina Gina makes the
same deal with u Bonney and um that was
the beginning of um
of
uh me
fixing more races than anybody in the
history of the world at Major racetracks
that involved all the top
jockeys in the
world I had to come up with 16,000 a
week 15 of it just for viig just to Vig
so I don't know if your audience
understands what Vig is V Vig is
interest
the banks call it interest the Wise Guys
call it Vig two points two points a week
is 2% of whatever you owe and that's
what you pay in my case I owed 7,200 in
Vig to cert and uh none of that comes
off the top uh so you still owe you
still owe the so in other words after
three years I paid him a million dollars
in v and I still load the
380 so that that's just let your
audience know
what what that is so so now I devised
the plan and I won't get into how or
where because we'll be here until
December um how I what I did and how I I
I what I did I devised a plan through
the help of um an old retired
jockey and this is all documented by the
way this is in all the newspapers it was
a big court case and everything else so
whatever I'm saying is
is uh not make believe it it
happened and um I uh I got a hold
of KH Rico who was a retire not retired
he he was an oldtime jockey that knew
all the
jockeys and
um and um he he still kept his jockey
license to ride at yonas and I mean to
ride it aqueduck and Belmont this is
Thor breads now
and um he U he knew all the jockeys so
through another jockey called um who was
a good friend of mine called Manny Yuka
he was another Hall of Fame jockey I met
with Conor Rico and I made him a
deal and the deal was that if he can get
to ycaza I mean to cardero and bazer and
all of the top jockeys that were riding
at um at Belmont and and duck um he
could make a lot of money I says you
think you can do that and he says of
course I could do that he says all these
guys I I raised them all I you know they
they they ow everything they got to me
so I says okay I says now from this
point on you can't tell me things that
you can't do for sure you can't just say
yeah yeah yeah you got to make sure you
know all these guys you know who the
good guys are you know who the bad guys
are you know know who you can trust you
know who you can't trust here's the deal
every day you go to the track you get
the program and you look at all the
races and try to pick the short Fields
meaning eight nine horses fields and try
to get the first second and third choice
out now let's say for instance Angel
Cordo is on the favorite give him $5,000
to be worse than third say baz's on a
second Choice give him $5,000 to be
worse than third and then the third and
fourth or fifth Choice see who you can
get out try to get another two guys out
give them 2500 a piece now for every guy
you get out you get
$1,000 so if you get four guys out of
the first race uh you're going to make
$4,000 just for that one Race c and the
drivers will get 5,000 5, 2500 2500
so each race that you fix for me will
cost me between 20 and
$25,000 I'm going to bet another
$25,000 leaving them horses out boxing
the
remaining um four horses or five horses
whatever is in there because like I said
before once the favor especially first
and second choic is out of it all that
money is still in the
pools and um so I just take 20,000 and
just box the remaining four horses for
the rest of the money and all I'm
looking to do is double my money which
many many times it's you wind up winning
a lot more than that but just double my
money do two three races four races a
day and you double your money you wind
up with two 200,000 a day right around
there and that that's what my plan
was and
uh so to do this um I hooked up Tony
Schuler who was the guy Whitey bulis guy
who followed me up to New
York um and um I put him in in uh Conor
Rico in a hotel right off the Long
Island Expressway right near Aqueduct
and Belmont racetrack and every morning
Khan was to go to the track and see what
he could do come back and tell Tony Tony
was supposed Tony called me and Tony
would bet at the racetrack and I would
send my Runners to all the OTB offices
around and that's what that's what
happened and I because of that I was
able to make my Vig payment every week
plus take care of my houses and the
girls and my nightclub life and all of
that and and things were
good until two or three weeks later when
um Tony from calling every day
he started to call every other day then
every third day and then every fourth
day and then once a week and then he
stopped calling at at all he never
called I drove up to the hotel they
checked out and um I was surprised I
wasn't surprised at him because he was a
fat phony who I didn't like but I
made a lot of money with him I just
didn't like him he just he just threw
his weight around thought who the hell
he was and always pulling that Wise Guy
even though he didn't with me um
but threaten all the jockeys and
everything when he didn't have to do
it um and that that created a couple of
problems probably one death a couple of
bad
beatings and um he was just not a nice
guy but a guy who you know you make a
deal with a devil you what are you going
to do and you you try to get out of it
and and it's tough but this was a
perfect time for me to to just show a
little a little strength something I I I
didn't want to do but I I have one
problem well I have a couple of problems
but one of them is
um I have a problem turning the other
cheek especially when I'm right that
could never happen and this guy just out
and out he's just a beat artist
and he thought who the he was and
and he forgot that the same way he grew
up is the same way I grew up and it
ain't going to
work so um I start getting myself uh in
trouble because the money I was making I
never made enough money in one
week uh to pay off kert because that's
who I wanted to pay off I never made 4,
380,000 in one lump sum in one week
where I could have just went them and
said here I never did that probably what
I could have done was maybe go to him
with 100,000 or 150,000 and say listen
here 100,000 take it off the top let me
pay the two points on 280 instead of 380
but I never did that maybe he would have
did it maybe he wouldn't I don't know
he's a he's a mad man so
um so now I'm I'm I'm getting myself in
a bit bit of a problem my savior was
Charles scoty who owned a Nev hotel in
Monella
racetrack I won't get into how we became
such close friends um because I can't
get into everything you know it's be too
long but he became a very very good
friend and um he knew the problem I had
and he allowed me to cash checks up to
$50,000 and for times like this when
Tony wouldn't call I started a
three-state kite going I opened up
um um checking accounts in um in New
York and Delaware and
Pennsylvania and uh I started a kite
going so if I and back then they had no
computers so it would take 10 days I
could cash a check from say Delaware at
the racetrack for say $30,000 and and um
they would cash it and I had I had like
10 days to make that check good so as
long as I had cash flow and that that's
what a kite does you just go from state
to state to state have a place to cash
him just make sure that check never
bounces and as long as you have cash
flow you could live like a a millionaire
and not have a penny as long as you have
cash flow as long as you can juggle so
that's what I was doing and
um and jeie was helped me a lot in that
area running around from state to state
and depositing monies and all this stuff
and and one
day um one of my Runners
Charlie he comes to me and he says Larry
he says there's this guy in Philly one
of scaras
crew um scafo
um I think his name was I think they
called him the crow I'm not
sure and um he said he has counterfeit
money you buy 10 cents on a dollar you
buy 100,000 course your
$10,000 and he showed me one of them and
they look really good and I says okay
and I bought 100,000 wor and then we
were going to mix it in with some of
other money through the bets and
everything plus I had a couple of
tellers that would uh you know I would
give them a hundred bucks or something
you can bet $1,000 and just try to wash
the money and
um Charlie tries to go buy a car with
some of the counterfeit money he got
caught goes to
jail and I went up to see him one month
and uh he says he somebody I want you to
meet so I I go meet him I go I I met him
and who was it Frank colada now Frank
colada for you folks who don't know
Frank colad was Tony spalatro button guy
the Chicago crew sent spalatro and and
and um and Frank colada to Vegas to kind
of watch the skim and take over that
whole town which they did in fact the
movie Casino is that's what it's about
Joe pesi play played the part of Tony
spalatro and I think Frank colada had a
part in that movie he played himself and
U but anyway um I I I I meet Frank and
Frank tells me he says uh Charlie was
telling me he had a problem he says and
I think I can help you with this problem
he says I get out in a month or whatever
it was he says here's my mother's phone
number uh call me and uh we'll see if we
could straighten this mess out he says
can you hang on till l and I says well I
got no choice hang
on so he gets out I call him up and I go
see him and uh he U he says listen we
got to go see Tony but uh I'm on paper
parole I I'm not supposed to leave but
he won't see you without me so we're
going to fly to Vegas we fly to Vegas I
tell Tony the whole story and I says if
this guy calls we'll be able to make two
three solid bets uh
every day and spalatro was another sick
Gambler and um and at the same time I
think it was the Stardust Hotel was
opening up a sports book that same year
plus um they
were many many many
bookmakers independent bookmakers that
spalatro basically threw out of town he
was dying to bust them out plus he had
his own bookmakers and he didn't care if
they busted them out because they come
back to him for for money and he charged
him a couple of points for the money so
he didn't care but we we did that he
winds up sending me he winds up uh we
fly back with with the three
guys one of the guys was Blitz Blitz
Blitz blitzstein um I I forgot blitzin
blitzstein I think is a big big gigantic
guy bottom line is we they fly back we
wind up looking for them and we find
them
and they stick a gun up his mouth almost
through his head and um the problem was
solved now we start making money again
Tony spalatro is Happy Frank Gad is
Happy everybody's happy and we're making
a lot of money but still not enough to
in one shot to straighten that thing
out so after about a month um they have
to go back so when they go back
naturally they threatened him but
naturally they went back and and Tony
started the same
and then they uh they left the
state I I I I think
um and the reason uh um well I know they
left the state uh and I found out
later why and how they left the state
they went up to Hazel Park in Detroit
and Hazel Park is run by the whole whole
Detroit mob and they were being
investigated and Tony Falls right in the
middle of that trying to fix races up
there and they all that's when he got
arrested and that whole mob up there got
arrested um because they were trying to
do something at Hazel Park which the mob
owned so
anyway I jumped about a year ahead but
um now during this time when Tony
disappears again I find myself in
trouble again making these these Vig
payments and and
um
um I was kiteen like crazy and it it was
just getting it was just getting
tough um and and the races I was fixing
at monacello they had no handle there I
mean so even though I was fixing two
three races a day and and fixed the last
race superfecta every night I I still
couldn't reach the 15 16,000 I needed
every week and I was getting myself
potentially in a bad
spot and then one day I got a call from
the matred at the Concord hotel where I
used to go every single
night and
um they had the biggest nightclub
biggest Lounge the best bands and I was
there every night and I get a call from
the matri day who I knew very well and
he says Larry says maybe you do me a
favor I got some friends up here from
the old neighborhood they came up to see
Natalie Cole's opening
debut uh at the um at the Raleigh Hotel
but they can't get
rooms and uh they can't get seated in
the in the
showroom so can you help them
out so I I went to meet him and and who
is it um it's four black guys it was
Nikki bonds and Robbie Jazz and um Leon
Leon bats that was part of the coun crew
they had in Harlem drug Nikki B was one
of the major drug dealers in case you
people don't know in
Harlem and uh I had horses at the time
with Bobby Parker who owned the Concord
I had horses with Manny Halbert who
owned the Raleigh Hotel I had horses
with with slusky who owned the monacello
Raceway in the Nev Hotel I had horses
with all the hotel owners up there
because of so I made a call and
naturally I got them rooms I got them
front table for Natalie Cole and and um
so Nat they thankk me they wanted to
give me money I wouldn't take it and
they said well let me buy a dinner I
said I've got to be at the racetrack
tomorrow night so he said we'll have
dinner in the dining room and that's
what we did so after dinner I said
listen I says was nice meeting you guys
I have to go I have a horse in the last
race so Nikki bonds Nikki says to me
says U oh tell tell me you see it was a
Superfecta race last race at monosol so
I says look you can't bet there's no
handle here I says we just fix it every
night and each of us get a ticket we win
2 3,000 each and and that that that's it
so um he says well um all right uh but I
want to see you after the races I says I
meet you at the Concord I meet him at
the Concord and he says to me he says
listen he says I can get down 5,000 a
position uh on horse racing and and I
says Nikki I says look I don't mean no
disrespect but they ain't a bookmaker in
the world going to take a bet on on
troton Races it ain't gonna happen much
less 5,000 a position meaning 5,000 win
5,000 plays 5,000
show and he says they'll take it he says
um he was betting with Fat Tony Fat Tony
so learning from the gigantic crew from
the genev crew um because Robbie had a
gas
um Nikki had a gas station I I I think
it was 120 fth Street or I think it was
120 fth Street Linux it's the B it's the
proper now where Al shopton has his
building that used to be Nikki's gas
station um garage and fatony had right
down the street he had where his Club
was where they used to hang out he says
listen we bet over close to $2 million
every week on sports with Tony he'll
take he'll give me a courtesy bit and I
says he won't give you it'll never
happen so he says all right I'm going
home uh I'll call you he calls me the
next day he says he'll take the 5,000
position so now I was in U I was in big
action but it was a different way of
fixing a
race before I used to eliminate four
horses and uh eliminate the Gamble from
gambling
now I couldn't box four horses I needed
a winner and I couldn't get seven guys
eight guys out of a Race So I had to
figure out how I could bet on a
winner and at the same time eliminate
the Gamble from gambling the only way
you could do that is to switch horses so
at the time I had about 30 horses in
monello so I got a hold of the equipment
guy who I knew for 10 years and I says
Ronnie I says listen I says um I'm going
to make you an offer if you don't want
to do it make believe we never had this
conversation I says I'm going to bring a
horse in I says now just to give you an
example and for your audience let's say
it's a $3,000 claiming race and I'm
going to instead of bringing that horse
in I'm going to bring in a $220,000
claiming horse that looks identical to
him but with a different tattoo you're
going to have a th you're going to get
$1,000 for every horse that I have in
just passing by just look at the tattoo
make believe it matches and just go so
if I have two horses in a night you'll
get 2,000 a night if I have 10 in a week
you'll get uh you you'll make $110,000 a
week
so he agreed so that's what I did I just
switched horses back and forth naturally
they weren't claiming races because I
wouldn't put a $220,000 horse and a
3,000 claiming race I just use that race
as an example they were all condition
races so that's that's what I did and we
made a lot of money I would get half of
uh the
$2500 uh the $5,000 bet $2500 of it
would be me and then to pump up the odds
a little bit uh I would um send one of
my Runners to the to the track and um
let's say I was driving the the five
horse I would send him up and everybody
knew he was my runner in the whole grand
stand so I'd send him up with couple
hundred to bet on the Seven Horse so now
word get through the whole grand stand
Larry's betting on the Seven Horse so
the whole racetrack bets on the Seven
Horse they make him the favorite the
horse we're I'm really betting on as my
horse them odds went up we made a lot of
money but that only lasted for um maybe
three three months and then the whole
Harlem crew got pinched they all they
all went away for life and then that
ended again so now I'm right back to the
same place I was back to before only
worse now because there was no finding
Tony because he got pinched in at Hazel
Park in in
Detroit so now I'm uh
um um there's no way for me to make this
so I I I went to seek aert and I said
listen I says I've been paying you now
two points on this
money for almost three
years you got almost a million dollars
in VG in them three years three times
more than what I owe you two ttimes and
um I can't do it no more the feds are
starting to close in the commission's
starting to close in everybody's
starting to close in Schuler got
arrested in in Detroit and um before
something happens because I don't want
to have if I go away I don't want to go
away owing you a money and then have a
problem in
jail so whatever I give you from now
on Stop The Vig let it come off the top
and I'll do my best just to get even up
with you and he agreed and um I made the
same deal with u with
Bonnie and um things were going along
all right because even if I had 2,000 I
would go down there if I had 10,000 I
would bring it to him and kept knocking
off the the
balance and
um and then one day
um Gina calls me and she says Bonnie's
not doing well he he's the last couple
of days he won't get out of to bed he
don't want to eat he don't want to thing
and um I says all right I'll come up
there and I looked at him I said Bonnie
we got to get you to the hospital he
said no no no I'm not going to no
hospital so I leave and next day she
calls me and she says Bonnie's in bad
shape I go up there again I call an
ambulance that take him to the
hospital uh when he gets to the hospital
that night me and Gina
have dinner and she says you know he
um he told me that um he left me
something in his
closet there's a shelf he says move the
Shelf out of the way and there's and
there's something he wants me to have it
all he has no family has
nobody so I says well what was it she
says I don't know I didn't I didn't look
I says well let's go look there was over
400,000
and probably most of it was my money
anyway but um it was 4 over
400,000 I took that money I paid what
balance what I owe cert me and Gina went
to Florida had a good time and U and
that was that's
basically um the end of my race fixing
career um with a lot left out a lot of
good stuff left out how I did did it um
and where I did it and
um I went into
um a few other things that uh we can't
get into now because it'll go but a few
other exciting
situations so um I know we don't have
all day here so uh basically that that's
it that was uh and what I did was um I
created the biggest race fix in
scheme um that was successful in the
history of horse racing through it all I
met a lot of top mob guys
because um I was in a nightclub every
night every nightclub was owned by a mob
guy and um sometimes that got me in
trouble because you you you go in a
place and there's a certain band that
you're following and you you go in there
and you get a front table
and U you're helping the guy out with a
tip because after after a few times in
fact I'll tell you I'll jump back right
into the middle of it in 19 in
1974 John Gotti gets a hold of me now
John Gotti I Know John from we were kids
when I was 16 years old and thrown out
of school my mother for punishment put
me uh first on the waterfront with my
uncle Pepe and then
I kept losing my money in crap games
every day so she got me out of there she
put me with my cousin Pete at Midstate
Midstate Spectre and mass bit a trucking
outfit and they put me on a night shift
G gassing up
tractors and um and one day my cousin
calls me and he says listen he says tell
John Computer the guy who was the
switcher tell them to park the street
trail three Street trucks coming in of
Cy sock whiskey tell them to detach him
in the hold them yard they're going to
be here for a couple of weeks and gas up
the tractors put them back up
front so when I was there naturally I
was I was Robbin um robing back then now
now I'm back to being 16 years old and I
still needed money for my cars and uh I
was I was robbing all the big trailer
truck
tires um and uh stocking them in the
garage where I had my stock car and I
was um and robbed the three Trail loads
of Cy sock whiskey and I needed a fence
I needed a place to put them and back
then
um uh because you're a thief and Robin
everybody knows everybody so I got a
hold of through a friend of mine John
Gotti who was 17 years old at the time
just just like myself and he had a guy
that um had a bunch of catering halls
and we sold the trail the the three
Trail loads of Cy Sal whiskey to him
unloaded them we whacked up the money
and that was my first meeting with John
Gotti and we did a lot of stuff after
that as far as swag goes and everything
so anyway and right around
1974 he gets a hold of me and he says I
heard you're doing something with uh my
man in Jersey because word gets around
like crazy when you're fixing races and
doing well word gets around before you
know it everybody knew so um I said here
and I told him the story and naturally
there was nothing he could do for me
because when you're wrong and you own
owe a mob guy money you can't have
nobody step in for you because the mob
guy has all the right in the world to
say he owes me the money you want to
stick up from him pay me the money so
but John did say I'll see what I could
do which I knew was uh he
couldn't he couldn't really do anything
but um uh I told him I would help him
out um and um and and and I did and one
day I met with him and um he said listen
he says says uh if you ever find a nice
horse he says I'll buy I'll I'll buy a
horse maybe we can have some
fun so to make a long story short I
found him a horse $5,000 horse had eight
quarter cracks you don't know what that
is so I won't get into that but I
patched them up I fixed them up and the
horse was ready to win and I was bought
from yakas at the time I gave him to
Herve filon who was the leading driver
in the whole world at that time and but
a good friend and I said Herve and I
told him the story about the horse I
says he's classified in the cheapest
class he'll win all the way up to the
best class he'll win 1011 in a row I
don't want you to around I want to
win with this horse I told him who own
them I says and all I want from you is
give me two horses every week that I
could use an exactor races underneath
them or in trifectas and he did and I
would meet his U his his uh one of his
top guys Frank Frankie lassio uh who was
with the Bronx crew well he was in the
Bronx but he was with with
geneves uh I mean
Gambino and uh uh I would meet him every
night tell him and John wind up making a
lot of money horse win 11 races in a row
and I put the horse under my mother's
name he win 11 races in a row win over
100,000 in Pur money John calls me one
day and he says I got to see you he says
we got to get rid of the horse I'm going
I think I'm going away I can't beat this
rap and he did he wind up going to jail
but not before I sold the horse I come
there with all the money uh and uh he
gave me half of all the money aside from
all the money we made gambling he gave
me half the money um half of 200 and
something thousand he gave me half of it
and he wind up going to
jail um so the these are all little bits
and pieces of stories that that I left
out but we can go on forever but um um
people do another one one day well do
what what whatever you want to do I mean
what what have you learn I mean is the
whole world
corrupt uh well I'll I'll tell you you
you you learned a lot of things when
when you when you put in positions that
I was put
in
um
being being rich one day poor another
day being involved with mob guys you
learn a few things you learn that um not
to trust anybody you learn that um
uh everybody has a
price you learn that U connections and
money can probably get almost anything
done you learn how to read people so it
it keeps you out of a lot of trouble I
mean right now I could walk into a or
meet somebody and and within two minutes
I I just know this is not a guy I want
to be around you you just learn how to
read people whether it's their face the
way they talk the way they car the way
their ears are set eyes are set whatever
it's just that when you pay attention to
that from the time you're a kid you
learn these
things and the thing that I learned that
bothered me the most was um in 1981 I
won a major race I won one of the the C
Pace it was like the M race in the
triple Crow it's the biggest harest race
in in the in the country and and I won
it and um that year in 1981 I decided to
have a Christmas party for all my
friends
friends and their families and I
couldn't find a place I tried Madison
Square Garden for the entertainment I
tried to get fat stomo and and I had all
the money I needed it so that wasn't a
problem this was an
8081 and
um
um I found a
place I was having trouble getting the
Madison Square Garden caded but the
biggest problem I had I couldn't I had
over 3,000 people on my list and I
couldn't find rooms for in Manhattan so
I go call her Bobby Parker and I says
Bobby I says I want to have a party you
close your hotel the Concord Hotel every
year for 10 days General cleanup open it
3 days early I want to hire your whole
crew your whole staff and I need it for
three days I'm having a party he says no
problem the only problem is you can't I
can't hold 3,000 people you got to cut
it down to like
11,00 so I sat with a friend of mine and
we tried cutting it down now here's the
moral of the story at that time I
thought I had 3,000
friends and um it was a hell of a job
cutting it down to a
thousand
and five years later I'm on a park
bench
broke and um I called up a friend of
mine for a pistol I was going to rob the
bank down the
street and
um he don't show up but he shows up who
shows up my friend Joe Mara the guy who
helped me cut the list down from 3,000
to1 and he says what are you doing I
says Joe I says I lost all my appeals I
got no license I got I don't know what
to do I'm
penniless uh I've been living off all my
credit cards they all reach the limit
I'm 880,000 in debt with that I said
I've been sleeping on this bench
now for the last three days I've been
eating down in the supermarket I go down
there I fill the card up with with
everything and while I'm walking through
the aisles I'm making sandwiches and
then I just leave the cart I says but
the next supermarket's five
miles away I can't be walking I said so
I I had it I say so I said it I
said uh I'm just going to take a shot
with the bank if I if I'm if I do it
I'll have three 4,000 if I don't the
state will feed me he says get in the
car get get in the car and he takes me
to Angelo's
restaurant and he buys me lunch he says
remember that day four or five years ago
I help you knock you you you didn't know
who to eliminate from the you thought
you had 3,000 friends he says you know
in the real world in real life if you
had to have a party for your true
friends all you need is this table and
they might be a seat empty we're at a
table for four and these are the things
that you learn when you go through
what I went through unfortunately um I'm
83 years old and um all the wisdom that
I have it's going to go to waste because
to get where I am I had to go through
these experiences and now I'm too old to
do anything I'm luy I can walk to my car
so so um them them them are the things
so what I change anything that I ever
did in my whole life no because I have
the DNA in me is makes me what I am I
just wanted to race I wanted to go fast
I love competition follow a leader was
never my thing music competition speed
and girls was my whole life and during
them times is is is uh as as rough as it
was in them years were the best times I
ever had in my life and and you also
find out that the things that you want
when you have nothing look better from
afar when you don't have them because
when you do get them it's like is that
all there is you know what the do I
do now I have this I have this I have a
boat I have this I have this I have this
and and and you you find so so I had
enough of everything and before it got
boring um I I I
either shot up or shot back down so my
life life was always changing but um and
the one thing that
um they're WR writing I never went into
this but they're writing a TV series now
about my whole life and
um and what they say to me all the time
is you got to bring girls into you got
to bring girls into it and I don't I
don't talk about that stuff but I I will
say
this there isn't I don't think Errol
Flynn well nobody knows who Errol Flynn
I had as many girls as I needed
in in my life I just don't talk about
that stuff uh but uh if if uh so so
there was never a a problem with women
in in me um never I just don't talk
about it but I'm going to have to talk
about it because they keep saying to me
we have to bring women and and and back
then they the the only woman in in the
series that we're writing is is Gina and
Barbara the girl at the bank suvan
County National Bank that taught me how
to open up accounts and kite checks and
all of this stuff but there were plenty
in in between I just don't talk about
them did
the the race fixing destroy your your
love of racing and
competition no well no what what what
what what it destroyed was uh my
reputation but had it not been for that
but you loved racing oh I and fixing
races is not racing any longer no but I
I didn't do that for profit I did it to
save my life I I would have much rather
uh just a legitimate way I didn't fix
races and I didn't do I did what I did
to save my
life uh from a a mad man who had no
problem putting one right between my
eyes and which he did 17 times in in in
New Jersey I don't know how many he did
in New York because later on when John
Gotti became the boss he made him a
captain and and now he's but then he he
wind up going to jail Samy the guy was
betting with he he went to jail for
murder too they were just they were just
bad guys that's why I fixed the races I
fixed it out of sheer desperation I did
not fix it because like I said before
the the the money I was making enough
money especially when I was successful
that short period of time I was making
plenty of money I didn't I didn't need
what what's your biggest
regret my
biggest my my biggest regret uh I I
really don't have any be I I really
don't have any regret my biggest regret
was was when when when um um uh H
hurting my mother during the my
childhood years when I didn't even
realize it
because nothing haunts
me at night when I'm when I'm sitting
watching television or when I'm trying
to go to sleep nothing haunts me more
than the hurt I put on my mother during
my childhood years just a selfish
selfish kid that had it was it was
terrible I had respect for everybody in
the Free World except my mother and and
and that's my biggest regret everything
else I did I did because I had to do and
after a while it becomes basically a way
of life and you don't even think about
it but I I have to say is as horrible as
is that
was is the the good times in my opinion
far outweighed the bad and they lasted
just long
enough uh where you wouldn't get bored
before you hit bottom again and then you
long for them days but to stay at the
level I was at when I was at that level
after a while it gets boring I mean you
know how much money do you need to to do
your daily how many how I had seven
Homes at one time with a girl in each of
them different states two cars in each
garage full water wardrob of Armani
suits what the how much you know
for what reason but I did it because I
raced in California so I bought a house
in California you race in Delaware you
buy a house in Delaware you meet girls
there so so I that's why I saiding about
the girls I don't forget when they built
the Sha stadium in Corona they built a
St um Stadium Vie in it's a hotel seven
floors had a girl on each floor see I'm
starting to talk about girls now cuz I
got to remember these things because
they want to put them in series so I I
had you know but it got to the point
where like my friend Ray CA uh he owns
all these major Mercedes dealerships all
high-end
cars the guy became a billionaire
selling
Mercedes and now he builds these big
yachts and now he's sitting home alone
he's sitting on his yacht what you know
he's just there's nothing else there's
nothing else to do there's nothing else
to buy there's nothing else and now he's
starting to get fat and this and that
and then coid happens he's scared to
death to go
out that's so I I re the only thing I
regret is is is what I did to my father
I and I I didn't tell that story because
it's just I'm G tell it real
quick let's hear it you want to save it
for next time okay we'll do another one
yeah it's a that's a sad story yeah sa
save for next time you have a
fascinating life story thank you Larry
my pleasure all
right